Speaker 1: . It's great to welcome to the program
today, Dacher Keltner, who's a professor of
psychology at UC Berkeley, the faculty director of
the Greater Good Science Center, and also author
of the book The Power Paradox, which we're
linking to. It's great to have you on today.
Speaker 4: David, it's great to be with you.
Speaker 1: So I feel like this conversation
is just so relevant in terms of even just
thinking about American politics right now
and the types of leaders that have have done
well and not so well over the past many years.
Maybe just to start with, my understanding
of the sort of Machiavellian view of power
is that at a very crude top level, it's
better to be feared than loved in terms of
maintaining influence and and maintaining that
power. What are the flaws with that approach
generally and maybe in particular today?
Speaker 4: Yeah, you know, the Machiavellian
approach of power you nicely summarized, David.
You know, let's remember it emerged in the early
15, hundreds, probably in one of the most violent
times in human history. And Machiavelli wrote this
book, The Prince, and some people question whether
he was really being sincere. But the idea of power
there is that you lie, you deceive, you pretend
that you're religious when you're not and you
kill your enemies and you destabilize your allies.
Right. So power is about fear and and acquisition,
sort of unilateral acquisition. And we've
really changed dramatically as a human society
in those five hundred years, as everybody
knows. Right. With works, more complicated,
politics are more complicated. We've seen the rise
of rights of different kinds. And so it's just a
different world. And when you look at empirical
tests of the Machiavellian perspective, do you
believe that you should lie and manipulate and
hurt others to rise in power? What you find
is those people don't do as well in
organizations today. They don't do
as well in American politics. You know, the
classic Machiavellian was President Nixon,
who's now rated as one of the least effective
presidents by historians. And we've even done
studies showing they don't do as well in finance.
And what are the more Machiavellian context? So,
you know, what I argue in the power paradox is
it might be time to abandon that philosophy of
power. It's been wildly influential. I think it's
I think it's at the source of a lot of today's
environmental and social ills.
Speaker 1: What do you think or what do you make
of the often repeated idea that the more unchecked
and or unilateral power one has, the more likely
they will be pushed into bad acts or corruption
or whatever the case may be? Is it that simple?
Speaker 4: I think it's it's it's a broad
hypothesis that you just articulated with
many versions. Right. The idea of a
democracy is you keep power in check.
And when it's not kept in check, as you
suggest, David, things get into trouble.
The idea of journalism is that you you speak truth
to power. You hold the powerful accountable. When
President Trump tries to destabilize
the idea of facts and journalism,
we have the trouble we have today, right.
Where people question the very notion of a
shared democracy. So, yeah, it's it's fundamental.
And you know what's really interesting, David,
when I did the research for the power paradox,
this is actually a very old idea and the evolution
of our human species. Right. Hunter gatherer
societies, hundreds of thousands of years old,
very sophisticated analysis show did this.
They kept the powerful in check through
social processes, through reputation, through
various things that gave rise to our critical
oversight of the powerful. And I really worry,
as you probably do, too, that, you know,
when we lose those capacities to keep the
powerful in check, you get into serious trouble
Speaker 1: is is the sort of Machiavellian
approach to power and governance in the modern
day, essentially equivalent to authoritarianism
in the sense that, you know, when I think of now
about being feared, I think about Duterte, I think
about Kim Jong un. I think about Putin. I think
about Assad. I sort of think about Trump in that
I think he would like to be that, although maybe
because of his cartoonish nature, he failed to
actually do it in practice. But he like a lot of
those authoritarians as well. Is that analogous?
Speaker 4: It is. And it very much this
Machiavellian view of dominate, coerce, lie
and manipulate scare very much finds a home.
In authoritarian politics and in fact, some of the
most authoritarian politicians in human history,
like Mussolini, were huge fans of
Machiavelli, right. And kept it kept
the prince as a leadership guide. And I agree.
I think that Trump wanted to be that, but was
kept in check by Wall Street and corporations and
the like. And so, thank goodness in some sense. So
it does Machiavellianism. Machiavellianism is very
closely allied with authoritarianism, even in the
American citizenry. We just published a paper
showing. Kind of it's interesting, you know,
white men who have been disenfranchized in
the United States tend to want that kind of
political philosophy to lead. So it's it's OK.
Speaker 1: And do they want it because they feel
that it will, as they see it, re enfranchise them?
Speaker 4: Exactly. You know, and I know. And
so it's this interesting quality of
American politics that that we have
to grapple with. That's pretty self-evident.
Speaker 1: I'm this is maybe getting more into
sort of the psychology of power in some sense. But
I'm curious what you think of it. There is this
I don't know if it's like a survivorship bias
sort of thing or I don't know exactly what I
would call it. But there's definitely this idea.
And this happens, I think in the business world,
this happens in the political world and elsewhere,
where once you achieve a certain amount of power,
success, influence, whatever, over time you
become accustomed to it and you sort of start
to think that like it. It had to be this way.
It was it's this way because I deserve it or
it's this way because I'm better or whatever
the case may be. And it's very hard to fight
that even sometimes when I like, will mentor
smaller YouTube ers or something like that.
I because I've been doing this for so long, I'll
sort of think like, well, you know, the I just did
some really basic stuff and it just sort of like
happened and it would have happened regardless.
But it really actually it's the work and it's the
day to day, et cetera. There's nothing inevitable
about a lot of the stuff. Now, how does that
psychological aspect play into how this evolves?
Speaker 4: You know, I think that's such an
astute observation and, you know, I think one
of the most pernicious dimensions to American
politics is this dynamic you're referring to.
We've studied it in the form of essentialism,
right. Which is what you find in corporations
and you find in organizational structures
is this idea of people who have power
start to become blind to the breaks they got, the
sources, the opportunities that came their way
by where they were born or the just by fate.
And they start to develop a sense that it takes
special people to lead. Right. And it is this
sense of like, wow, I have power of power. There
must be we justify it and we think, wow, I'm some
sort of uniquely gifted person to rise to the top.
And why is that perilous? Because No one it leads
to and we've done work on this certain kinds of
ideas about compensation. Well, maybe I deserve
20 million dollars a year for the work I do.
Speaker 1: It's like a veil
of meritocracy. In a sense.
Speaker 4: It is. Very much so. Very much so.
And and the idea of meritocracy. Right, that
it's really the special people that, you know,
that get into the special schools or deserve
certain kinds of compensation or
get treated by the law differently,
which we have ample evidence of. So I think it's
a really dangerous corollary of the psychological
dynamics of power that the powerful think they're
above the law and deserve more than other people.
Speaker 1: There's these studies that have been
popularized over the last few years about how
being wealthy, particularly for a long period of
time, starts to change the brain in some way. And
like what exactly that means, we can talk about
it. And it's kind of like the devil is in the
details. But does being in a position of power in
the way that you study also have a similar effect?
Speaker 4: Yeah, you know, and this is work
by Super Under Obbie in Canada and Naomi
Eisenberger at UCLA. I mean, it's astonishing
that you can give somebody you can place somebody
randomly into a position of power. Right. I could
take you and randomly assigned you to like, hey,
you're in charge of other people and you're the
powerful one. And one of the big effects at the
neurophysiological level is that it it tends to
deactivate the empathy regions of your brain.
Speaker 1: So I've got to do some tough stuff.
I might not have done this before, but now that
I'm in this position, it's just what I have to do.
Speaker 4: Right. But what I worry about with the
deactivation of these empathy regions and we've
also found power deactivates the vagus nerve,
which is a big bundle of nerves in your chest and
helps you connect and be kind to other people. So
suddenly when powerful people are acting and
more greedy fashion, they're not sensitive
to suffering. They're not aware of other
people to the extent that they used to be.
We now have a neurophysiological understanding
of that. That power know one person put it
dramatically, like it shuts down your empathy
regions. That's a little dramatic, but
it's on the way towards what's true of power.
Speaker 1: So the paradox, or at least what one
one of the paradoxes that you talk about is if
individuals or groups or whoever, they get power.
And the idea is that they're being empowered in
order to do things for a group of people. But
the more power they get for a lot of the different
reasons you've talked about starts to limit their
ability to really fully think about how they can
keep the interests of of everyone sort of in mind
in their actions. Right. I mean, like this is
sort of the paradox that we're talking about.
Speaker 4: Yeah. You know, and you just nailed
twenty five years of my life studying power. But
thank you, you know. Yeah. You know, what's
surprising, what may surprise people is that
once you start thinking deeply about it, there's
a lot of truth to this. And we've looked at like
who gains power in Hunter-Gatherer societies,
sports teams, non-profits, government, even
finance, et cetera. And it's people like you said,
David Who and Hannah Arendt really put it well,
as did Michelle Fuyuko, who you gain
power by advancing the greater good,
by advancing the interests of the people
around you. That is just a basic law. Right.
And so you do it through promoting strong
social networks and and sharing knowledge
and distributing resources that leads you to rise
in the ranks. And then, regrettably, through these
psychological processes we've been talking about,
once I feel powerful and I'm seduced by myself,
you know, I start, you know, acting unethically
and failing to attend to people's thoughts or
recommendations and not feel. For other people,
so that's the paradox of power is, is we rise
in some sense to advance other people's interests,
but when we feel powerful, we work against it.
Speaker 1: Have the stakes sort of changed in the
sense that, for example, like in Jared Diamond's
work, he's written a lot about how the ability to
cooperate and the ability to advance the greater
good for your maybe clan of one hundred and fifty
people at that point not being the team player,
etc.. You could be out and you could be
dead. Right. Like, the stakes were very,
very light. Life or death maybe in some senses in
twenty, twenty one that applies. But it feels as
though maybe the stakes have changed to a degree.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I think that's the big question.
Right. Which is and you put it really and this
is Christopher BOEM who really wrote about
hierarchies and that Jared Diamond's commenting
upon, which is that you had to cooperate and
be interdependent and work collectively to
survive for a couple hundred thousand years.
And today, in some sense, a lot of
the basic processes that enabled
that cooperation have been degraded. Right.
So our ability to hold leaders accountable,
you know, in the financial collapse of
2008, I don't think anyone I think one
person was prosecuted. Right. So that just
means you can go do whatever you want to do
if you're white and privileged and not be held
accountable. That's problematic to this mob,
this cooperative model of power. I worry about
certain contexts that teach this Machiavellian,
you know, self-interested above others model
of of how to lead. You know, you see that in
important institutions like, you know,
certain business schools and certain views of
economic views of human nature. So. So, yeah. You
know, I think you're you're framing it. I wish I
had framed that in that fashion in the power of
prayer, which is we had this workable model of
power. Right. For hundreds of thousands of
years. And now it's been degraded and we see
levels of greed and environmental destruction
even that come out of this model of power that we
that may cause our demise.
Speaker 1: The book is called
The Power Paradox. We've been speaking
with the book's author, Dacher Keltner,
professor of psychology at UC Berkeley. So great
having you on. I really appreciate your time.
Speaker 4: Thanks for your
thoughtful questions. David.